so regarding the recession how cognitive
do you think joe biden is literally do
you think he's driving anything do you
think he has any original ideas
whatsoever because here's my thought
there's no way in hell he's on the
ticket in 2024 and he knows it so i
think if he's cognitive enough that he's
thinking about legacy right now he spent
his whole life in government
and i think it's it's his motivation is
to not be the worst president so he's
making day-to-day survival decisions not
leadership decisions because he's
trending to be as bad as jimmy carter i
mean that's who you compare him to right
now so my question is do you think he
has is he calling the shots on any of
this or is he just back hopefully
reading the prompt or not screwing that
up
i mean that's i think that he's waking
up in the morning to a b12 shot and his
handlers and their whole goal is for him
not to say something stupid i don't
think anything's coming out of him i
think it's his corrupt team that's
pushing this progressive narrative i
mean all the all the dad is there like
when he has a cue card telling him where
to sit at your chair and you have to
capitalize your i mean at this point
you're not even coherent and i was
making fun of it there for a while but
to me as like a an american and i love
this country like my family it is my
family it's given me everything it's
terrifying it's absolutely [ __ ]
terrifying and then when everybody goes
hey well he needs to step down i'm like
so you want kamala harris in there
like
it's just it's bad form right now and
bro i don't even think democrats want
him to step down because they're afraid
kamala to run it because it's even going
to be worse no notice how much they hide
kamala from the camera yeah so it's not
like i know it's you can't find her
anywhere these days no but by the way
you know what i knew a lot of good
friends in high school and in in middle
school and junior high school and this
this is pure
shout out to kamala harris i had a lot
of good friends that were great at hide
and go seek she's the champion i mean
i've never met anybody that's good as
she is at it do you do you think um
like
what's your opinion on on biden right
now because
i mean
where does it go so for me i've said
this many times i think in life
in companies the sooner you realize
whether you are a number one
a number two a number three a number
four or a number five six seven eight
nine ten the better you're going to do
if you plug in an eight to be the one
that company's gonna collapse
if you put a one in a seven you're under
utilizing the one and eventually that
seven is going to leave and be a one
elsewhere okay
but a one is a one
and a five is a five
and you just have to understand that it
took carmilla years to realize that you
want to win a championship you're not
gonna win as a one ai didn't win as a
one okay westbrook so
you have to know and by the way this is
by far one of the hardest thing to
embrace
it's the hardest thing to embrace to
know that you're not a1 okay
so biden to me
i think bernie sanders is moral one then
he's a number one i know this sounds
weird but forget about being a socialist
i think sanders is a
in the socialist community he is a one i
think in the democratic policies i don't
think he's the one i think there's
plenty of guys that would be better ones
than he would be
so i don't see the guy as a leader i see
him as a potential number two number
three i think two is even high i think
he's a number three four five five guy
do you think the administration has a
responsibility to tell the american
public the the his health
or you saw the interview with pete did
you see the interview with pete when
pete was being pushed yesterday i don't
know if you guys saw that or not where
to judge pete
did you see that or no he was being
pushed yesterday
and he says hey uh uh i don't know who
was pushing him but he was asking very
good questions says listen in 2019
uh you
you posed the question that you don't
think
president trump was mentally fit to run
america
and
president trump wasn't stumbling and
then he shows all these pictures by the
way you have to see this interview you
know we'll find it and we'll post it and
he says president trump wasn't stumbling
president trump wasn't shaking hands
with ghosts president trump wasn't being
told where to sit president trump wasn't
doing any of that stuff how come you're
not publicly
calling out the mental fitness of joe
biden as you did of trump and it's ten
times worse and obviously pete buddhich
says i i can see the level of insult in
your question
so i will dismiss that he says no no you
can't do that you you said
president trump three years ago wasn't
mentally fit to run the country
and he never went through what this
guy's going through he says well i'd
love to see president trump ride a
bicycle that's what he said about the
fact that yeah
there was a doctor that came out and
said the same thing a doctor that
treated trump and biden
and he said what was it same thing i
think it was the exact same question
but that's that's how they respond right
you put a cat in a bathtub and they just
react with violence or anger um and then
no logic you know just answer the
question you see this everywhere you see
shapiro put guys in that position you
see all these all these and they just
can't respond they they
get mad and say well that's offensive
and walk out of the interview like
that's not debate that's just you being
a child here's my question you're lost
if biden is better as a number two which
i actually fully agree with i don't
think he's well i think he's side
dealing i think he's i think he's the
accidental president the timing you know
covid trump you know
exactly his polling wasn't obviously
doing so great biden he was more the
conservative democrat not the leftist
bernie sanders but would you have a
problem if in fact obama was helping him
call the shots behind the scenes or even
a susan rice i think that gives me a lot
more comfort if someone quote unquote
grown up in the room was actually
helping run the government rather than
biden meaning he's not exactly who you
want in charge or do you want him in
charge because he is the president i i
don't have a problem if quote unquote
his handlers i don't think it's like the
daycare staff i think it's susan rice i
think it's um secretary of state i think
it's tony blinken i think there's some
people
around him who i do
trust enough to control the government
so do you have a problem if it's obama
actually calling the shots let me ask
you a question uh do you think if you're
in my ear you can help me be a better
basketball player
yeah i can you think you can do that
like you should show your form you can
show me form just like if i can you if
can he
probably help me be a better but shooter
but no matter how much you're in my ear
can you help me play in the nba no sir
why not
some things you just can't teach what if
what if jordan's in my ear
let's say jordan every day spends two
hours in my ear telling me how to be a
better basketball player am i going in
the nba probably not the nba but your
mentality you'll probably get a lot of
shows everybody
has limitations in different areas of
life
president biden's limitation at best is
a vp of opera vp of ops not a president
i'm with you so even the point i'm
trying to make to you is i can go and
talk to a vp of ops to be the ceo of an
insurance company
and no matter what i tell that vp of ops
in his ear he's not going to be able to
execute there's a lot of experiences you
need you need to be a leader
and biden just doesn't have it today
maybe 30 years ago i don't know maybe he
would have been different if his mental
fitness was different but he doesn't
have the capacity today to be a
impressed so if you like this clip and
you want to watch another one click
right here and if you want to watch the
entire podcast click right here
[Music]